all that much and here well this is the
best player on the planet Magnus Carlson
I am stoked to see these two go out it
because when they went head to-head over
the board in Toronto as the first moves
are underway Dennis laik was a few
careful moves away from making a draw in
that first game but ultimately it was
Magnus who came out on
top Magnus starts with the white pieces
uh Dennis is so strong with white
himself so Magnus will see this as a
chance to strike and he starts with the
English opening but already a pause here
um this is a bit of a surprising pause
from Magnus surely he's going to bring
out the other white knight or he's going
to push a pawn he's had this position
countless times before but Dennis is
well prepared already Magnus in the tank
for 30 seconds um Tanya the English
opening really part of magnus's Arsenal
but why is he thinking what is he
thinking about at this early stage I'm
as surprised as you are and while Magnus
thinks let's remind everyone the switch
up the losers bracket is the best of two
the Winner's bracket is the best of four
this is the first game game Magnus
perhaps just trying to think about what
kind of opening structure he wants now
to my knowledge David D3 is not the most
topical move very often why goes Knight
F3 wants to strike in the center with D4
Magnus took his time is this what he
calls the anti- young player
chess I would say so uh it's just taking
the opponent out of the book giving them
a lot of choice giving them strategic
questions um like you say it's not one
of the main moves um actually I'm going
to eat my words this isn't the English
opening this is the Sicilian Defense
just with colors reversed and white has
an extra Tempo having started the game
first so um yeah Magnus he's hoping that
Dennis who isn't a one E4 player who
doesn't play Sicilians on the opposite
side he's hoping he's a bit
uncomfortable so black has gone for what
we would call an open Sicilian here it's
just kind of trading off Pawns in the
center White's going for what we would
call the Sicilian Dragon setup with the
beautiful Bishop on G2 and the game will
now proceed very very quickly look at
that Bishop a real sniper so many
Targets on that diagonal but Dennis has
reacted almost instantly since this
small surprise um I've got to say Robert
really impressive speed and Confidence
from the youngster impressive from
Dennis surprising from Magnus I'm not
sure what he's thinking about on each
and every turn uh this is a standard
looking position but from colors reverse
and I would imagine and he finally does
play Knight to F3 that that would be the
most logical continuation to the left of
our board we see the win percentages in
high level games stemming from this
opening and white does have a slight
lead but many of these games are drawn
and that's what Dennis lasic is known
for it sounds weird to say oh that kid
is known for drawing but really he just
doesn't lose very often it doesn't
matter who he's facing it doesn't matter
what color he has he rarely loses games
of Chess and that includes over theboard
tournaments at the highest level it
includes the Champions chess tour title
Tuesday he is super solid and this is
anything but solid from Magus Knight to
G5 I mean he's playing some offat kg
chess and if I'm Dennis I think I just
occupy the center I think I might want
to bring my knight up to D4 there are
oftentimes tricks available if white
isn't careful on this E2 Square so I
think that Magnus he's uh just trying to
catch Dennis off guard but Tanya this is
a still stable stuff from the
17-year-old and that's what he's known
for stable chess we've seen him we've
seen his games very few times you'd see
Dennis make some decisions that leave
him with a long-term weakness he really
likes to play these strategic fights to
me it was really fascinating what you
said earlier when Magnus went into an
early think that he's just trying to
think where can he go where Dennis might
not be too familiar and he takes this
reverse Sicilian setup up a move simply
because Dennis is not an E4 player
himself so perhaps trying to get him
into Waters where Dennis might not be
too familiar but I like the speed with
which he's played I like the fact that
Dennis has kept a position which doesn't
have weaknesses eventually we might even
see a light Square Bishop trade it
wasn't possible on the previous move cuz
the Knight on D5 was H was hanging but
if black is able to trade off that E6
Bishop for the G2 Bishop very often
black solves all opening problems
because the one Trump that Magnus has in
this position is the bishop bar Robert
yes this bishop on D2 that's supposed to
be a beneficial piece but there aren't
useful diagonals to work with it's
staring into its own night there are
actually no accessible squares along the
diagonal as I'm putting them all in red
because black controls all of them so so
far it's been a stable game for both of
these players and Magnus as David said I
think he really called this correctly
he's just trying to get a bit of a
longer game and outplay Dennis later on
and we already can see that with a
semi-open C file there is some valuable
Terrain in front of this Rook especially
if this Knight moves out the way David
what do you make of this move A5 I think
it's clear that's why Dennis Mar has
Fook to d8 but do you like the setup
that he is opting for yeah I think it's
uh very sound as Tanya mentioned that
Dennis has limited experience in this
porn structure and uh often if a player
I know the viewers at home might be
thinking this as well if you play a new
opening if you're forced into new ground
it takes a while to figure out where to
put the pieces but he's defending
everything here Dennis he's going for
centralization the White Queen the white
sorry the black queen the Black Knights
the black Bishop all really well placed
can't fault those and now he's employing
magnus's favorite thing against him
pushing Rooks pawns just gaining space
on the flanks it always looks mysterious
it always looks like it's playing on
kind of an irrelevant side of the board
but Pawn to A5 if that black pawn pushes
further later on could become a real
battering ram it kind of takes away some
of white major plans on the queen side
white normally would want to push pawns
A3 B4 so um yeah I think Dennis has
handled this really well it hasn't cost
him that much time on the clock he's
still within his comfort zone got
everything covered um like you were both
saying he's just this immovable object
Dennis the Conqueror no no it's Dennis
the Invincible as long as he doesn't
lose he's uh he's happy so um yeah I
think in terms of objective evaluation
he's solved all his problems he's
totally fine as black it's just about
later in the game whether he can kind of
maintain that composure when Magnus
inevitably does start to ask some
difficult questions starting with this
move Queen to A4 um Robert a bit
tactically suspect a queen on A4 often
but here it looks like it's fine for
white yeah Ty you take advantage of a
queen over here on A4 with tactics along
the diagonal loose pieces drop off you
always have to consider what happens if
the piece in between hops out the way I
want to show very quick variation so
let's bring up the analysis board
because some players might be looking
for tactics on this diagonal but Knight
takes C3 removing the guard of the queen
after B takes C3 let's say you hop in
with the Knight to D4 I thought the
evaluation would go all the way up in
White's favor but apparently it's not
that bad Knight takes E2 check
intermetzo was the point the king SL
sides of the corner Rook takes D7 I
thought that this Knight was just
trapped on E2 and it does look trapped
but amazingly this is ridiculous the
move that black has here is Bishop to C4
see this and then to properly assess I
get it that you can't take the bishop
because the bishop on D2 is loose but to
consider this position here where at the
end of things white has two Bishops for
a rook and apparently it's just level uh
this is a rook and two pawns for two
Bishops it's a mess but Dennis maybe if
he calculates this deep he can go for
this variation I thought it was
impossible but clearly there is a lot
that's going on here that does not
immediately catch the
eye but very often Robert it's not just
about calculating these kind of
variations but also evaluating that
final position as something that you
want on the board which can be very
challenging because to me looking at
that two Bishop versus Rook sure the
computer might say it's level but from a
human perspective you're never sure
because the Bishops can be super strong
against The Rook so it's also something
that perhaps Dennis isn't forced to go
so he's trying to think of many many
different options it's the kind of
position where chess is a complicated
game you can have different approaches
different plans we see the move Queen to
A4 and Dennis needs to think what pieces
to trade maybe he trades maybe he
doesn't maybe he sidest steps with the
queen but he's taking his time right now
David what would be your approach with
black in this position
um I think I wouldn't go for that line
just because uh I'd probably be too lazy
to calculate in a rapid game but also
partly because as Robert said it's so
difficult to uh evaluate and while
Dennis he's just traded off the Knight I
believe Knight takes Knight we're
heading in that direction Dennis he's so
good strategically for such a young
player really mature his kind of
decision making his end game skills but
also very sharp in terms of tactics so I
wouldn't have been surprised if he did
play Knight D4 but this is the
justification
he didn't need to enter those murky
Waters it's not his character he just
wants to trade off light Square Bishops
as you pointed out Tanya and he's doing
it in a different fashion uh but
probably equally effective white doesn't
really want to run away or block this
light Square Bishop trade because that
would really hamper the activity of
White's Bishops I think Dennis has made
a good decision and if we're left with
just queen of Knight versus queen of
Bishop as we've kind of touched upon
before that Dynamic can favor the side
with the Knight so um yeah again it cost
him a lot of time two three minutes
Dennis but as we've come to expect from
him Robert always a sound positional
decision from him and speaking of well
unsound positional decisions Pawn to F3
from Magnus the evaluation part doesn't
really budge so objectively this is a
good call I actually think practically
it is too because black had a clear plan
let's trade Bishops I do want to point
out that the tactic I was noting before
Knight D4 can always be met by Queen to
D1 to defend that lose Pawn on E2 here
you could successfully trade Queens but
I just want to note that that was not a
forc variation but after F3 there isn't
anything forced for black now Dennis has
to make another difficult decision and
what is the actual plan Tanya I actually
I'm appreciating this move from Magnus
he is just keeping everything under
control on his end and saying to Dennis
what are you g to do I have the bishop
hair and in the long run the Bishops May
Flex their might on the
diagonals keeping more tension on the
board if the Bishops are traded off it
really helps blacken the position the
Knight better than that Bishop it just
makes things so much easier F3
eventually black needs to take a
decision because Black's Bishop on D5
isn't very stable it can be kicked out
it might even fall back maybe F3 is a
move that Dennis actually provoked to
block that Bishop but look at that last
move by Dennis he clears up another
Square on C6 for his own Bishop he
really wants to keep it on this diagonal
making sure that he can neutralize the
bishop pair that white has I saw the
evalar it did not approve of this queen
trade but from a human perspective it
looks like a very practical choice to
make
David yeah yeah it makes sense getting
the Queens off it simplifies things
somewhat but this is kind of Magnus
playing anti- young player chess you
mentioned it that phrase Tanya while I
was off camera I quickly got out the
Oxford dictionary I checked what that
meant and it's pretty much getting the
Queens off don't allow your young
opponent any fun and any activity you
take the long-term advantage
here Magnus has the bishop pair we've
talked about and also the extra Central
Pawn and with all of those small
imbalances you try to tire out your
young opponents and uh of course Dennis
is no ordinary youngster it's no
guarantee that it will work but I think
this is Magnus again as Robert mentioned
just kind of asking small questions
later he'll again start creating threats
start pushing the white pawns which
pawns will he push who knows Dennis
isn't sure either so Dennis will have to
burn time watching out for moves like F4
in the near future and um yeah I
I don't really like the fact that he
trade traded Queens yes it made things
more simple but remember Bishop peirs
gaining power the longer the game goes
on the more the board clears up so this
end game I would think against anyone in
the world it would be a bit more
one-sided uh Magnus is on the white side
but yeah Dennis if he proves yet again
as he has done this whole week that he
can hang in these tight end games
against the world's best then he will
deserve uh this result F7 what do we
think of that Robert I like that move
from Dennis at some moment he can
consider bringing his Bishop back to D7
and F4 that's the big idea for Magnus
creating a pawn break but perhaps Dennis
won't allow the pure break and will push
himself to E4 just trying to ask
questions to White's Pawn structure so
so far there hasn't been pieces staring
at one another we're just seeing some
maneuvering but I do still think that
Whit's plans are easier and it's in part
because there are more pawns for white
in the center we see two Pawns for white
one on D3 one on E2 just one for black
and we have lovely Pawn chains for black
the pawns are a bit scattered and I do
think that at some point white will play
F4 you just have to time it correctly
and meet E4 with D4 so T I think that
Magnus he's in a quintessential Magnus
position you've put it really well and I
don't think there's anything scarier
than playing Magnus in these kind of end
games where M model like us might be
like this you know eventually will'll
fizzle out into a draw one of the minor
pieces might get traded off no
weaknesses for black matus Carlson is
already smelling blood here he's got the
bishop pair he's looking longterm he's
placed his rook in B1 F4 always in the
air although the last move by Dennis I
like it he puts that pawn on B6 you want
to place as many pawns on the dark
squares to limit the activity of that
dark Square Bishop that Magnus has
because that's the bishop that Dennis is
lacking in the position he's moved the H
Pawn I won't be surprised if you might
see G5 on the board as well trying to
restrict that F4 break that you were
earlier alluding to uh Robert it's far
from over but playing against Magnus
this is this can be a terrifying
position uh
David yeah for sure um this position
actually did appear on page 83 of gr
like a Grandmaster so Magnus has studied
it before and pawn F4 Robert it's this
big question what to do black has to
break the beautiful Pawn chain that
black has from G7 to E5 you have to uh
make a decision now to block it lock it
we just try to I'm I was about to say
maintain the status quo but you can't he
does indeed push his paorn forward what
do you make of these changes in
structure well I do like how quickly
Dennis is responding uh he is trying to
control the light Square so if the
Bishops had been traded then that Knight
would have just hopped into F5 but for
now that Knight on E7 it's a bit
restricted piece is fighting for the
same squares I won't be surprised if
Magnus uses his King but don't rush a
decision like that because at some
moment black can strike pushing this ewn
forward but if this white king I'm just
going to teleport it on over to E3 this
is a problem for black in many of these
positions I'm just you know hovering the
king over the square I'm blockading I'm
putting pressure on your E4 Pawn so this
E4 Pawn the main point is overextended
atata I still don't see easy plans for
Dennis he's shuffling back and forth the
engine isn't suggesting it's a winning
Advantage for Magnus nothing of the sort
but he just his moves just always easier
to play I think dnis just has to wait
right now he has to keep shuffling with
the Rooks like you mentioned keep the
position as is and let Magnus show what
is his improving technique here he plays
the move E3 so making sure that black
doesn't have that E Pawn push anymore
which at the right time would have
activated that Bishop gets the other
Rook into the game to me it's really
impressive the speed with which Dennis
is responding a position that's slightly
passive for him because for Magnus he's
playing not only the board but also
Dennis's clock so Dennis needs to make
sure that he has those extra seconds
that extra minute when those critical
decisions will have to be made and they
will come when you'll have to decide
which pawns to trade which pawns to push
in this position do you ever want to
make a move like G5 do you just want to
stay still so there are some big
decisions ahead on the road for Dennis I
like his speed David how do you think
you know Magnus best what do you think
is going on in his mind right now how
does he see this being played out Magnus
is just calculating I think he's turned
off the emotions here it feels like
Magnus has upped his game from yester
where there was a a bit of inconsistency
there are a few slip UPS here and there
he's just gone back to basics Magnus
kind of 1.0 the Magnus who first break
broke onto the scene where it's just
about grinding himself and uh kind of
look at this Pawn to C5 now undermining
Black's stronghold on the queen side I
think this is Magnus zeroing in you
mentioned being oppressed by Dennis the
speed T I was too but suddenly I look at
the clock and he's a minute and a half
down suddenly The Black Queen side on
the verge of collapse uh so yeah it
feels like Magnus is again keeping
things simple Rook to B2 there just
covering the A2 Pawn soon the white
light Square Bishop will come into the
game there we go it rots itself and yeah
I've got to say I'm very biased towards
the white position right now it looks
like black is just really tied up
defending everything and no active plans
um whe the Breakthrough is who knows
Magnus and Dennis both know better than
I do but right now it does look like
White's Advantage only growing kind of
incrementally Step by Step Robert every
single move and this Pawn on A5 is just
such a problem piece for black to deal
with if this Pawn were back on A7 you'd
feel like you'd a healthier structure
for now the Knight on C8 can't easily
get out because you might drop the B6
Pawn you don't want to take on C5
because then A5 will drop so here it's
about making that incremental progress
that we're talking about a bishop to E2
at some moment to also play G4 further
expansion but if you start trading pawns
it gives the black Rooks some file so I
love the way Magnus continues to play
his Rooks have I don't care about that
question get out of here with that
that's not a question mark move and I
don't even know what black should do to
respond it says Black's best move here
yeah it wasn't gonna be played Knight to
E7 giving away this B6 Pawn so if that's
the way to get out of it you're not
finding that as a human with one minute
and 15 seconds on your clock Magnus is
doing everything right in my opinion he
controls this
board look at that last move Point A3
he's in Zero Rush at all again
instructive for everyone at home when
you have a long Advantage when there's
no immediate threats from your opponent
you don't need to rush just slowly
improve he's freed up that white Rook on
B2 now it will no longer be tied down to
that pawn as Robert mentioned at some
point he might even play King to G2 to
defend the white H3 Pawn uh kind of let
the light Square Bishop loose to start
playing and Andis every single move he's
asked with a question what are you doing
how do you improve black Camp cannot
improve his position cannot create any
threats and that burns time on the clock
look at this 30 seconds Tanya the time
situation it looked under to control but
suddenly no longer it's always so
impressive how easy Magnus makes these
end gamees look he has this unique
ability to combine all these different
aspects in the position he first
advances on the king side gains the
space slowly improves the king puts the
Rooks on the correct uh the correct
files which potentially longterm can
open up so they're ideally placed
meanwhile Black's Rook doubled on the D
line but they're undermined by that D4
Pawn The Bishop's coming into play small
moves like A3 forcing Dennis to make a
move which is much harder when you lack
spaces and for Magnus Carlson it just
feels like the Magnus magic when it
comes to these end games and look at him
on the camera he looks so incredibly
confident and now Dennis has to hold
this position with is 20 seconds on the
clock complete control from Magnus
Carlson every single little move a pawn
push to get off the dag and by the way
Denis is getting really low on time and
that's when mistakes happen Advantage
growing and Bishop E2 a correct response
keeping that King Frozen opening the CNB
files but where is The Knockout there
must be something here or at least in
the near future as Dennis is under 10
seconds David and there we go Magnus
opens up a second front of attack he's
already probed away on Black's Left
Flank now he's switching focus and
hoping to overwhelm the black Army and
wow every move suddenly it's King side
then Queen side King side and queen side
and there we go Rook C6 he's infiltrated
Enemy Lines he's into the sixth rank
that black knight is so sad right now
Dennis's time situation sad as well 8
seconds left it's on the brink of
collapse as you say Robert still yet to
uh kind of click that Domino flick it
and uh for everything to start toppling
but Magnus is looking for the break
through um and here there's so many
tempting moves right now for white lot
of tempting moves and it's also so
instructive how Magnus kept improving
his position made these small moves and
only went for the G4 break when Dennis
was down to seconds because it's such a
difficult move to respond to and he
might give a check on C4 right now I
don't believe you can fall back with the
bishop I'm already looking at ideas like
the Deep on moving forward and that
would have been tactics that would have
worked in magnus's favor it just looks
like black pces are losing Harmony right
now The Rook is active the Knight on C8
there has to be something really strong
right now can white start thinking about
advancing the D Pawn does he put
pressure on the C8 Knight what's the
move here too many good options I'm
actually not sure nor is Magnus and
that's why he's doing the right thing he
is slowing down he pushes his Pawn to D5
that opens up a diagonal for the dark
Square Bishop but look at Dennis he is
hanging in there he may have seven
seconds left but his last few moves have
been solid Magnus is like how do I
actually win this game because if Dennis
gets his Knight out watch out mean
suddenly this becomes a bit messy and
White's King is feeling a little bit
lonely there could be checks against it
and things of that
nature and Den he's so resourceful we
wow Magnus sacrifices The Exchange I was
about saying Dennis NY never loses
because he defends better than most
players in the world and suddenly he's
oh he's given up another Pawn on the A5
Square magnus's D Pawn looks huge he
played that last move with three seconds
left Dennis it might be the crunch of
time trouble here a pin he needs to
react he defends his Bishop magnus's
Bishops are going to become monsters
there we go another Pawn drops it's
bishop and two pawns for the rook and a
check as Magnus seized it now Dennis
shaking his head Robert he's on the
brink yes a win for Magnus Carlson
resignation but it was time that did
Dennis lazic in you see the last move a
brilliant